This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you ever talked to your computer, cursed it for making a mistake? Peacey load letter. Is that me? Have you ever argued with the traffic directions you get from Google Maps or Ways? Starting route to Grover's Mill Road. Have you ever looked at a Rumba cleaning the floor on the other side of the room and told it, please come over to this side.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你有没有和你的计算机说过话，在它出错时咒骂它？加载信件。是我吗？你有没有和谷歌地图或韦氏导航给你的交通路线争辩过？开始规划前往格罗弗米尔路的路线。你有没有看过房间另一头正在扫地的Roomba扫地机器人，然后对它说，请到这边来。
Turn left. Left. It just ran itself right off the edge. Robot and artificial intelligence are playing an ever larger role in all of our lives. Of course, this is not the role that science fiction once imagined. It doesn't feel pity or remorse or fear. Robots bent on our destruction, remain the stuff of movies like Terminator, and robot Sentience is still an idea that's far off in the future. But there's a lot we're
向左转。左。它自己直接开到边缘掉了下去。机器人和人工智能在我们所有人的生活中扮演着越来越重要的角色。当然，这并不是科幻小说曾经想象的角色。它没有同情心、悔恨或恐惧。一心想要毁灭我们的机器人，依然只存在于《终结者》这样的电影中，而机器人的感知能力仍然是遥远未来的概念。但是，我们正在
learning about smart machines, and there's a lot that smart machines are teaching us about how we connect with the world around us and with each other. This week on Hidden Brain, Ken Robots teach us what it means to be human. My guest today has spent a lot of time thinking about how we interact with smart machines and how those interactions might change the way we relate to one another. Kate Darling is a research specialist at the MIT Media Lab. She joined us recently in front of a green robot dinosaur about the size of a small dog known as a play-o. It's going to be part of this conversation, but before we get to that, here's Kate. Kate, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. You found that there is an interesting point
了解很多关于智能机器的知识，智能机器也在很大程度上教导我们如何与周围的世界以及彼此建立联系。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨：机器人能否教导我们何为人类？我今天的嘉宾花了很多时间思考我们如何与智能机器互动，以及这些互动可能会如何改变我们彼此交往的方式。凯特·达林是麻省理工学院媒体实验室的研究专家。她最近和我们一起出现在一只小狗大小、被称为Pleo的绿色机器人恐龙面前。它将成为本次对话的一部分，但在我们讨论这个之前，先来听听凯特的分享。凯特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。你发现了一个有趣的现象：
in the relationship between humans and machines. And that point comes when we give a machine a name. I understand that you have three of these play or dinosaurs at your home. Can you tell me some of the names that you have given to your robots? Yes. So the very first one I bought, I named
在人类和机器的关系中。这个转折点出现在我们给机器起名字的时候。据我所知，你家里有三只这种Pleo恐龙。你能告诉我你给你的机器人起了一些什么名字吗？好的。我买的第一只，我给他起名叫
Yohai after Yohai Ben Banklor, who's a Harvard professor, who's done some work in intellectual property and other areas that I've always admired. And the second one I adopted after I filmed a Canadian documentary where the show host had to name the robot. And he gave the robot the same name he had, which was Peter. So the second one has a boring name. And then the third one is named Mr. Spaghetti. I don't know if people outside of Boston are familiar with this, but the Boston Public Transportation System, they wanted to crowdsource a name for their mascot dog. And the internet decided that the dog
Yohai，是为了纪念哈佛大学教授约海·本班克勒，他在知识产权和其他我一直很钦佩的领域做过一些研究。第二只我是拍完一部加拿大纪录片后领养的，当时节目主持人必须给机器人起个名字。他给机器人起了他自己的名字，叫彼得。所以第二只的名字很无聊。第三只的名字叫“意大利面先生”。我不知道波士顿以外的人是否熟悉这个，但波士顿的公共交通系统曾想为其吉祥物狗众筹一个名字，而互联网决定这只狗
should be named Mr. Spaghetti. And of course, they refused to do that and named the dog Hunter. So Mr. Spaghetti became a big thing in Boston for a while. It was, people were very outraged about this. And so I named my PLEO, my third one, Mr. Spaghetti. I understand that companies actually have found that if you sell a robot with the name of the robot on the box,
应该叫“意大利面先生”。当然，他们拒绝了这样做，而是把这只狗命名为了亨特。所以“意大利面先生”在波士顿火了一阵子。当时，人们对此感到非常愤怒。于是我给我的PLEO起名叫“意大利面先生”，这是我的第三只。据我所知，企业实际上发现，如果你在盒子上标明机器人的名字来出售机器人，
it changes the way people will interact with that robot then if you just said this is a dinosaur. So, this is, yeah, this is not, I don't have any data on this, but yes, I have talked to companies who feel that it helps with adoption and trust of the technology, even very, very simple robots, like boxes on wheels that deliver medicine in hospitals. If you give them a little nameplate that says Betsy, their understanding is that people are a little bit more forgiving of the robot, so instead of this stupid machine doesn't work, they'll say, oh, Betsy made a mistake.
与你只是说这是一只恐龙相比，人们与该机器人的互动方式会发生变化。所以，是的，我没有这方面的具体数据，但我确实和一些公司交流过，他们觉得这有助于提高人们对这项技术的接受度和信任度，即使是非常非常简单的机器人，比如在医院里运送药品的带轮子的箱子。如果你给它们一块写着“贝西”的小铭牌，他们的理解是，人们对机器人的宽容度会稍微高一点，所以人们不会说“这个破机器根本不好用”，而是会说“哦，贝西犯了一个错误”。
And I'm wondering if you spent time thinking about why this happens. At some level, if I came up to you at home and I said, Kate, is Mr. Spaghetti alive? You would almost certainly tell me no, Mr. Spaghetti is not alive. I assume you don't think Mr. Spaghetti is alive, right? No. OK. So given that you know that Mr. Spaghetti is not alive,
我想知道你是否花时间思考过为什么会这样。从某种程度上说，如果我在你家里走到你面前对你说：“凯特，意大利面先生是活的吗？”你几乎肯定会告诉我“不，意大利面先生不是活的”。我猜你并不认为意大利面先生是活的，对吧？不。好的。那么，既然你知道意大利面先生不是活的，
why do you think giving him a name changes your relationship to him? With robots in particular, it's combined with just our general tendency to anthropomorphize these things and we're also primed by science fiction and pop culture to give robots names and view them as entities with personalities and it's more than just the name right. I mean robots move around in a way that seems autonomous to us. We respond to that type of physical movement. Our brains will project intent onto it. So I think robots are in the perfect mixture of something that we will very willingly treat
你认为为什么给他起个名字会改变你与他的关系？特别是对于机器人，这结合了我们将这些东西拟人化的普遍倾向，而且科幻小说和流行文化也让我们习惯于给机器人起名字，并将它们视为具有个性的实体。这不仅仅是一个名字，对吧。我是说，机器人的移动方式对我们来说似乎是自主的。我们会对这种身体运动做出反应。我们的大脑会将意图投射到它身上。所以我认为，机器人完美地融合了某种特质，让我们非常乐意以
with human qualities or lifelike qualities. I understand from one of your papers that there have been examples, especially in military settings, where robots have been assigned to do very dangerous tasks, because you don't want human beings to go out and do those tasks. But eventually, the military folks who are running the robots start to relate to them as if they were actually fellow soldiers. There has been some research on this.
人类或生命体的品质去对待它们。我从你的一篇论文中了解到，曾有一些例子，特别是在军事环境中，机器人被指派去执行非常危险的任务，因为人们不希望人类去冒险。但最终，操作机器人的军人开始像对待战友一样与它们建立情感联系。这方面已经有一些研究了。
So Julie Carpenter has done some research. And there's just countless stories online on Reddit everywhere about soldiers becoming emotionally attached to the bomb disposal robots that they work with. They'll give them names. They'll give them medals of honor. They'll have funerals for them. And it's also kind of interesting
朱莉·卡彭特做过一些研究。Reddit以及互联网各处有着无数的故事，讲述士兵们对他们共事的排爆机器人产生了情感依恋。他们会给机器人起名字。会授予它们荣誉勋章。会为它们举行葬礼。这也是一件挺有意思的事，
because the robots aren't special robots. They're just kind of sticks on wheels, but I think just also the situation that the soldiers find themselves in where the robot is basically risking its life to save human lives might also lead them to become very attached to these devices. You had a wonderful example some time ago
因为这些机器人并不是什么特殊的机器人，它们只是一些带轮子的棍子，但我想，士兵们所处的环境——机器人基本上是在冒着生命危险拯救人类生命——也可能会导致他们对这些设备产生极大的依恋。不久前，你举过一个非常精彩的例子，
looking at a colonel, I believe. I don't know if this was your work or you were citing someone else's work. Of a colonel who was supervising a robot that was in doing sort of mind disposal. Tell us a story about the mind disposal robot. Oh, yeah, this is an incredible, it was an article in the Washington Post, I believe, back in 2007. And the United States military was testing this new robot that could walk over a field with landmines and diffuse them by stepping on them and blowing them up. And the robot itself was shaped like a stick insect so it would walk around on six legs.
对象似乎是一位上校。我不知道这是你的研究还是你引用了别人的研究。关于一位上校监督一个正在进行某种排爆作业的机器人。给我们讲讲这个排爆机器人的故事吧。哦，是的，这是一个令人难以置信的例子，我记得那是2007年《华盛顿邮报》上的一篇文章。美国军方正在测试一种新机器人，它可以在布满地雷的田野上行走，通过踩上去并引爆来清除地雷。这个机器人的外形像一根竹节虫，靠六条腿四处走动。
And every time it stepped on a landmine, one of the legs would blow up. And then it would just continue on the remaining legs. And so they were testing this, and the colonel who was in charge of this exercise ended up calling it off because he said it was too inhumane to watch this thing drag itself across the field on its remaining legs. And so this raises sort of an interesting question because at the one hand, we can understand
每次它踩到一个地雷，其中一条腿就会被炸毁。然后它就会靠剩下的腿继续前进。他们在测试这个项目时，负责这项演习的上校最终叫停了，因为他说看着这东西用剩下的腿在地上拖行实在是太不人道了。这就引发了一个有趣的问题：一方面，我们可以理解
how this desire to anthropomorphize robots is very human in some ways, but in some ways in this case, that defeats the whole point of having a robot that's trying to find the mind. It does. I mean, it's really anything from inefficient to dangerous in these contexts where we want robots to be strictly used as tools to anthropomorphize them. And it's a very difficult design challenge as well because how do you create a device that people want to use but don't like too much? All right, so we have this wonderful little prop in front of us. It's a play or dinosaur.
这种将机器人拟人化的欲望在某些方面是非常人类的，但在另一些方面，在这个案例中，这违背了拥有一个旨在寻找地雷的机器人的初衷。确实如此。我的意思是，在这些我们需要机器人严格作为工具的语境中，拟人化从低效到危险不等。这也是一个非常困难的设计挑战，因为你如何创造出一个人们想用但又不会太喜欢的设备？好了，我们面前有一个很棒的小道具。这是一只Pleo恐龙。
I want you to tell me a little bit about the play or dinosaur, how it works, and how you come to one three of them, Kate. What is the dinosaur? What does it do? It's basically an expensive toy. I bought the first one, I think, in 2007. There we go, it's awake. They have a lot of motors and touch sensors, and they have an infrared camera and microphones. So they're pretty cool pieces of technology for a toy,
我想让你跟我多聊聊这只Pleo恐龙，它是如何工作的，以及你是怎么拥有其中三只的，凯特。这只恐龙是什么？它是做什么的？它基本上是一个昂贵的玩具。我想我是在2007年买的第一只。看，它醒了。它们有很多马达和触觉传感器，还有红外摄像头和麦克风。所以作为玩具来说，它们是非常酷的技术产品，
and that's initially why I bought one because I was fascinated by everything that it can do. Like if it starts walking around, it can walk to the edge of the table, it can look down, measure the distance to the floor, it knows that there's a drop and it'll get scared and walked backwards. And then they go through different life phases adolescent and fully grown. And it'll have moods. So I think what we should do, we bought the robot at Hidden Brain a couple of weeks ago.
这也是我最初买一只的原因，因为我被它能做的一切迷住了。比如如果它开始四处走动，它可以走到桌子边缘，它可以向下看，测量到地面的距离，它知道那里有一个下落点，然后它就会感到害怕并向后走。然后它们会经历不同的生命阶段：青少年期和完全成熟期。它还会有情绪。所以我想我们应该做的是，我们几周前在《隐藏的大脑》买了这只机器人。
We haven't had the chance to give it a name yet. And I thought we should actually reserve the honors for this evening, where we're talking to Kate, and see if Kate wants to try and name this dinosaur. Since she cares about dinosaurs so much, I was looking up Kate's Twitter feed this morning. I understand that you're going to have a baby soon, congratulations. Yes, they don't have a name for that either. Okay. Just FYI, she sometimes refers to the baby as baby bot, so just for whatever that's worth. And one retweet that you have on your Twitter feed cracked me
我们还没有机会给它起名字。我想我们应该把这个荣誉留到今晚和凯特交谈的时候，看看凯特是否想试着给这只恐龙起个名字。既然她这么关心恐龙，我今天早上查了查凯特的Twitter动态。我知道你很快就要生宝宝了，恭喜你。是的，他们也没有给那个孩子起名字。好吧。顺便说一句，她有时把这个宝宝称为“机器人宝宝”，所以就当是这么回事吧。你在Twitter上转发的一条动态把我
up, it said, you don't really know how many people you don't like until you start trying to pick baby names. Yeah, that's a quote from my husband. So I don't want to tell me, you apparently haven't yet picked your baby's name. So do you have any choices of top choices? Is there a name, a spare name that you might care to give the dinosaur? Well the problem is we've had a girl's name picked out for years and now we're having
逗笑了，上面写着：“直到你开始尝试给宝宝起名字，你才真正知道有多少人是你讨厌的。”是的，那是我丈夫的一句话。所以，我不想问你，显然你还没有选好宝宝的名字。那你有什么候选的前几个名字吗？有没有一个备用名字，你愿意给这只恐龙用呢？问题是，我们多年前就挑好了一个女孩的名字，现在我们要生的是
a boy and we just can't, we don't even have any contenders. No contenders. What would have been your favorite girl's name if you had had a girl? Well, so when I first started dating my now husband, he at some point said, if I ever had a daughter, I already know what I would name her. And I was like, oh, really? Oh, my God. We're going to fight about this one.
一个男孩，我们简直没办法，我们甚至连候选名字都没有。没有候选名字。如果你生的是女孩，你最喜欢的女孩名字是什么？嗯，当我刚开始和现在的丈夫约会时，他有一次说：“如果我以后有个女儿，我已经知道该给她起什么名字了。”我说：“哦，真的吗？天哪。我们要为这个争吵了。”
And he said, yeah, I would name her Samantha and Sam for short, because Sam is kind of gender neutral. And I was like, oh oh I really love that. So that one was picked out very easily. Alright since you're not having a girl you're going to have a boy would you mind if you considered naming the dinosaur Samantha? How would you feel about that? Oh that would be awesome we should name the dinosaur Samantha.
然后他说：“对，我会给她起名叫萨曼莎，简称萨姆，因为萨姆有点性别中立。”我说：“哦，哦，我真的很喜欢那个！”所以那个名字选得很轻松。好吧，既然你不是生女孩，而是生男孩，如果你考虑给这只恐龙起名叫萨曼莎，你介意吗？你觉得怎么样？哦，那太棒了，我们应该给这只恐龙起名叫萨曼莎。
Alright so henceforth this dinosaur will be called Samantha or Santa Shore. Now, some time ago, kid conducted a very interesting experiment with the play of dinosaurs and to sort of show how this works, I have a second prop here which is under the table. It's a hammer. A large hammer, which we borrowed from the hotel. Now, as you all know, the dinosaur is obviously not alive. It's just cloth and plastic and a battery and wires. It has a name, of course, Samantha. But it isn't alive in any sense of the term.
好的，所以从今以后这只恐龙将被命名为萨曼莎或桑塔肖尔。现在，不久前，凯特用Pleo恐龙做了一个非常有趣的实验，为了展示这是如何运作的，我这里还有一个藏在桌子底下的道具。是一把锤子。一把大锤子，我们从酒店借来的。现在，如大家所知，这只恐龙显然不是活的。它只是布料、塑料、电池和电线的组合。当然，它有一个名字，叫萨曼莎。但它在任何意义上都不是活的。
And so, Kate, I'm going to actually give you the hammer. Oh no. Kate, would you consider destroying a Samantha? No. It's just a machine. I only make other people do that. I don't do it myself. You wouldn't even consider harming the dinosaur?
所以，凯特，我实际上要把这把锤子交给你。哦，不。凯特，你会考虑摧毁萨曼莎吗？不。它只是一台机器。我只让别人做那种事。我自己不干。你甚至不会考虑伤害这只恐龙吗？
Well, so my problem is that I already know the results of our research and that would say something about me as a person, so I'm going to say no, I'm not willing to do it. Tell me about the experiment. So you had volunteers come up and you basically introduced them to these lovable dinosaurs and then you gave them a hammer like this and you told them to do what? Well, so, OK, so this was the workshop part that we used the dinosaurs for. They're a little too expensive to do an experiment with 100 participants.
嗯，我的问题是，我早就知道我们研究的结果，那会说明我作为一个人的特质，所以我要说不，我宁愿不做这件事。跟我讲讲这个实验吧。所以你让志愿者走过来，基本上把这些讨人喜欢的恐龙介绍给他们，然后你给了他们这样一把锤子，让他们做什么？好吧，好吧，这是我们使用恐龙的工作坊环节。用它们来对100名参与者进行实验有点太昂贵了。
So the workshop that we did in a non-scientific setting, we had five of these robot dinosaurs. We gave them the groups of people and had them name them, interact with them, play with them. We had them personify them a little bit by doing a little fashion show with a fashion contest. And then after about an hour, we asked them to torture and kill them. And we had a variety of instruments.
所以在非科学背景下举办的工作坊中，我们有5只这种机器人恐龙。我们把它们分给不同的人群，让他们给它们起名字、与它们互动、和它们玩耍。我们让他们通过办一场时装秀和一个时尚比赛，把它们稍微人格化了一点。然后在大约一个小时后，我们要求他们折磨并杀死它们。我们准备了各种各样的工具。
We had a hammer, a hatchet, and I forget what else. But even though we tried to make it dramatic, it turned out to be a little bit more dramatic than we expected it to be, and they really refused to even hit the things. And so we had to kind of start playing mind games with them and we said, okay, you can save your group's dinosaur if you hit another group's dinosaur with the hammer.
我们有锤子、短柄斧，还有别的什么我忘了。尽管我们试图让它变得很有戏剧性，但结果证明它比我们预期的还要戏剧性得多，他们甚至真的拒绝去打这些东西。所以我们不得不开始对他们玩心理战，我们说，好吧，如果你用锤子砸另一个组的恐龙，你就能拯救你们组的恐龙。
And they tried and they couldn't do that either. This one woman was standing over the thing trying and she just couldn't, she ended up petting it instead. And then finally we said, okay, well we're gonna destroy all of the robots unless someone takes a hatchet to one of them. And finally someone did. Wait, so you said unless one of you kills one of them, we are gonna kill all of them?
他们试了，但他们还是做不到。有个女人站在那东西旁边尝试，但她就是下不去手，最后她反而去抚摸它了。然后我们最后说，好吧，除非有人用短柄斧砍其中一个机器人，否则我们要摧毁所有机器人。最后终于有人动手了。等等，所以你们说除非你们中的一个人杀死其中一个，否则我们要杀死所有机器人？
Yeah, I think this might have been my partner's idea. So it did this with a friend named Honest Gossult. We did this at a conference called Lift in Geneva and we had to improvise because people really didn't want to do it. So we threatened them and I think he doesn't want you to harm her. Yeah, clearly, clearly. So what do you think is going on? I mean, at a rational level, the dinosaur obviously is not alive. Why do you think we have such reluctance to harming the dinosaur? In fact, I might have the battery removed so the dinosaur stops making noise.
是的，我想这可能是我的搭档出的主意。所以这是我和一个叫Honest Gossult的朋友一起做的。我们在日内瓦一个叫Lift的会议上做了这个，我们不得不即兴发挥，因为人们真的不想这么做。所以我们威胁了他们，我想他不想让你伤害她。是的，很明显，很明显。所以你认为发生了什么？我是说，从理性的角度来看，这只恐龙显然不是活的。你认为为什么我们对伤害这只恐龙会有如此大的抗拒？事实上，我可能会把电池取下来，好让这只恐龙停止发出噪音。
Well, I mean, it behaves in a really life-like way. I mean, we have over a century of animation expertise in creating compelling characters that are very life-like, that people will automatically project life onto you. I mean, look at Pixar movies, for example. It's incredible. And I know that a lot of social robotists actually work with animators to create these compelling characters. And so, you know, it's very hard to not see this
嗯，我的意思是它的行为方式非常像真的。我是说，我们有一百多年在动画领域的专业经验，能够创造出非常逼真的引人注目的角色，让人类会自动将生命投射到它们身上。我是说，看看皮克斯的电影，例如。这太不可思议了。而且我知道许多社交机器人专家实际上都在与动画师合作来创造这些引人注目的角色。所以，你知道，很难不把这个
as some sort of living entity, even though you know perfectly well, that it's just a machine, because it's moving in this way that we automatically subconsciously associate with states of mind. And so I just think it's really uncomfortable to people is particularly for robots like this that can display
看作某种有生命的实体，即使你心里完全清楚这只是一台机器，因为它的移动方式是我们潜意识中自动与精神状态联系在一起的。所以我只是认为这让人感到非常不舒服，特别是对于能够表现出
you know a simulation of pain or discomfort to have to watch that. I mean it's It's just not comfortable. What did you find in terms of who was willing to do it and who wasn't? I mean when you looked at the people who are willing to destroy a dinosaur a dinosaur like the Pleyale You found that there were certain characteristics that were attached to people who were more or less likely to do the deed. So the follow-up study that we did, not with the dinosaurs, we did with hex bugs, which are a very simple toy
疼痛或不适模拟的机器人来说，看着这一幕让人觉得很不舒服。我是说，这真的让人不舒服。从谁愿意动手谁不愿意动手的角度来看，你发现了什么？我是说，当你观察那些愿意摧毁一只恐龙——像Pleo这样的恐龙——的人时，你发现那些更有可能或更不可能付诸行动的人身上有哪些特定的特征？所以我们做的后续研究，不是用恐龙，而是用Hexbugs（六足虫），它们是一种非常简单的玩具，
that moves around like an insect. And there, we were looking at people's hesitation to hit the hex bug, and whether they would hesitate more if we gave it a name, and whether they would hesitate more if they had natural tendencies for empathy, for empathic concern. And we found that people with low empathic concern for other people, they didn't much care about the hex bug, and would hit it much more quickly.
像昆虫一样四处爬行。在那里，我们观察了人们在击打Hexbug时的犹豫程度，观察了如果我们给它起个名字他们是否会更加犹豫，以及如果他们本身具有同理心和同理心关怀的自然倾向，他们是否会更加犹豫。我们发现，对他人缺乏同理心关怀的人，他们不太在乎Hexbug，会更快地击打它。
And people with high empathic concern would hesitate more, and some even refused to about the hex bug and would hit it much more quickly. And people with high empathic concern would hesitate more and some even refuse to hit the hex bugs. So in many ways what you're saying is that potentially the way we relate to these inanimate objects might actually say something about us at a deeper level than just our relationship to the machine. Yes, possibly. I mean, we know now, or we have some indication that we can measure people's empathy using robots, which is pretty interesting. You know, my colleagues and I were discussing ahead
而具有高度同理心关怀的人则会犹豫更久，甚至有人拒绝……关于Hexbug，他们会更快地击打它。而具有高度同理心关怀的人会犹豫更久，甚至有人拒绝击打Hexbug。所以在很多方面，你所说的是，我们与这些无生命物体的互动方式，可能在比我们与机器的关系更深的层面上说明了我们的一些特质。是的，有可能。我是说，我们现在知道了，或者我们有一些迹象表明，我们可以用机器人来衡量人们的同理心，这相当有趣。你知道，我和同事们在这次
of this interview, whether you would actually destroy the dinosaur, and we were torn, because we said, on the one hand, you of all people should know that these are just machines and that it's an irrational belief to project life-like values on them. But on the other hand, I said, you know, it's really unlikely she's going to do it
采访前讨论过，你会不会真的摧毁这只恐龙，我们当时很纠结，因为我们说，一方面，你最应该知道这些只是机器，在它们身上投射类人的价值是一种非理性的信念。但另一方面，我说，你知道，她真的不太可能会这么做，
because she's going to look like a really bad person if she smashes the dinosaur in front of 200 people. I mean, I don't know if you've been watching Westworld at all, but the people who don't hesitate to shoot the robots, they seem pretty callous to us. And I think maybe there is something to it. Of course, we can rationalize it. Of course, if I had to, I could take the hammer and smash the robot, and I wouldn't have
因为如果她在200人在场的情况下砸碎这只恐龙，她看起来会像个非常糟糕的人。我是说，我不知道你有没有看过《西部世界》，但是那些毫不犹豫地向机器人开枪的人，在我们看来显得非常冷酷无情。我想也许这其中确实有些道理。当然，我们可以为此寻找理性解释。当然，如果必须的话，我可以拿起锤子砸碎机器人，我也不会因此做噩梦。
nightmares about it. But I think that perhaps turning off that basic instinct to hesitate to do that might be more harmful than over, you know, I think overriding it might be more harmful than just going with it. I want to talk about the most important line we draw between machines and humans and it's not intelligence but it's consciousness. I want to play a little clip from Star Trek. Now tell me, Commander, what is data?
但我认为，也许关闭那种犹豫不决的基本本能可能会比超越它带来更多伤害，你知道，我认为压制它可能比顺其自然更有害。我想谈谈我们在机器和人类之间划下的最重要的一条界限，它不是智能，而是意识。我想播放《星际迷航》中的一小段剪辑。现在告诉我，长官，Data是什么？
I don't understand. What is he? A machine? Is he, are you sure? Yes. You see he's met two of your three criteria for sentience, so what if we meet the third consciousness and even the smallest degree? What is he then? I don't know. Are you? Do you? So this has been a perennial concern in science fiction, which is the idea that at some point, machines will become conscious and sentient. And very often, it's in the context of, the machines will rise up and harm the humans and destroy us.
我不明白。他是什么？一台机器？他是吗，你确定吗？是的。你看，他已经满足了你对有感知能力的三个标准中的两个，那么如果我们满足了哪怕是最小程度的第三个标准——意识呢？那他是什么？我不知道。你是吗？你确定吗？所以这是科幻小说中一个永恒的关注点，也就是在某个时刻，机器将变得有意识和有感知能力。而且非常常见的情境是，机器将奋起反抗并伤害人类、毁灭我们。
But as I read your research, I actually found myself thinking, is our desire to believe that the machines can become conscious, actually just an extension of what we've been talking about the last 20 minutes, which is we project sentience onto machines all the time. And so when we imagine what they're going to be like in the future, the first thing that pops in our head is, they're going to become conscious. Yeah, I think there's a lot of projection happening there. I also think that before we get to the question of robot rights and consciousness, you know, we have to ask ourselves
但当我阅读你的研究时，我实际上开始思考：我们渴望相信机器能够变得有意识，其实是不是仅仅延伸了我们过去20分钟一直在讨论的话题——也就是说，我们一直都在将感知能力投射到机器身上？所以当我们想象它们在未来的样子时，我们脑海中冒出的第一件事就是：它们将变得有意识。是的，我认为那里发生了很多投射。我还认为，在我们讨论机器人权利和意识的问题之前，你知道，我们必须问自己：
how do robots fit into our lives when we perceive them as conscious? Because I think that's when it starts to get morally messy and not when they actually inherently have some sort of consciousness. when they actually inherently have some sort of consciousness. There's a lot that's morally messy about how humans interact with robots. When we come back, we're going to delve into some of those moral and ethical issues, including the deeply troubling case of a Japanese company that builds sex robots designed to look like children. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. If humans have a tendency to anthropomorphize
当我们感知到机器人具有意识时，它们如何融入我们的生活？因为我认为正是从那时起，事情开始变得在道德上棘手，而不是当它们本身真正具备某种意识时。当它们本身真正具备某种意识时……人类与机器的互动中，有许多在道德上十分棘手的问题。稍后回来，我们将深入探讨其中一些道德和伦理问题，包括一个日本公司制造外表被设计成儿童外观的性爱机器人的极度令人不安的案例。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。如果人类有将机器
machines to see them as human, it isn't surprising that we're also willing to bring all the biases we have toward our fellow human beings into the machine world. Many of the intelligent assistants being built by major companies, Siri or Alexa, are being given women's names. Many of the genius machines are often given men's names, how, or what's in. Now, you can say, Siri and Alexa aren't people. Why should we care? Why should we care if people sexually harass their virtual assistants, as has been shown
拟人化、将它们视同人类的倾向，那么我们愿意将对同类人类的所有偏见带入机器世界也就不足为奇了。大公司构建的许多智能助手，比如Siri或Alexa，都被赋予了女性名字。许多天才机器都被赋予了男性名字，比如How或Watson。现在，你可以说，Siri和Alexa不是人。我们为什么要在乎？为什么我们要关心人们是否像有时被发现的那样对虚拟助手进行性骚扰？
to sometimes happen? MIT's Kate Darling says we should care because the way we treat robots may have implications for the way we treat other human beings. It might. We don't know, but it might. One example with the virtual assistance you just mentioned is children. So parents have started observing, and this is anecdotal,
麻省理工学院的凯特·达林表示，我们应该在乎，因为我们对待机器人的方式可能会对我们对待其他人类的方式产生影响。可能会。我们不知道，但可能会。你刚才提到的虚拟助手的其中一个例子就是儿童。所以家长们已经开始观察到，这虽然是轶事证据，
but they've started observing that their kids adopt behavioral patterns based on how they're interacting with these devices and how they're conversing with them. And there are some cool stories like there was story in the New York Times a few years ago where a mother was talking about how her autistic son had developed a relationship with Siri, the voice assistant.
但他们已经开始观察到，孩子们根据他们与这些设备的互动方式以及与它们的对话方式，采纳了相应的行为模式。有一些很酷的故事，比如几年前《纽约时报》上的一篇报道，一位母亲谈到她的自闭症儿子是如何与语音助手Siri建立关系的。
And she said this was awesome because Siri is very patient. She will answer questions repeatedly and consistently. And apparently this is really important for autistic kids but also because her voice recognition is so bad, he learned to articulate his words really clearly and it improved his communication with others. Now that's great but these things aren't designed with autistic kids in mind, right? That's kind of more of a coincidence than anything And so there are also perhaps some unintended effects that are more negative. And so one guy wrote a blog post, a well back where he said,
她说这太棒了，因为Siri非常耐心。她会反复且始终如一地回答问题。显然这对于自闭症儿童非常重要，而且因为她的语音识别实在太差了，他学会了非常清晰地吐字，这改善了他与他人的沟通。现在，这很棒，但这些东西在设计时并没有把自闭症儿童考虑在内，对吧？这更像是一个巧合，而不是别的什么。因此，可能也存在一些更具负面影响的意料之外的效果。所以有个家伙不久前写了一篇博客文章，他说：
Amazon's echo is magical, but it's turning my child into an echo because Alexa doesn't require please or thank you or any of the standard politeness that you want your kids to learn when they're conversing and when they're you know demanding things of of you so uh that you know it starts there but I think that as this technology improves and gets better at mimicking real conversations or lifelike behavior you have to wonder to what extent that gets muddled in our subconscious and not just in children subconscious but maybe even in our own. Do you think it's a coincidence that most of the virtual assistants are given female names and female identities? I think it's a combination of whatever market research but also just people not thinking.
亚马逊的Echo很神奇，但它正在把我的孩子变成一个Echo，因为Alexa不需要“请”、“谢谢”或者任何你希望孩子在交谈时、在你要求他们做这做那的时候学会的标准礼貌；所以，呃，你知道，一切始于此，但我认为，随着这项技术不断改进，在模仿真实对话或逼真行为方面变得更好，你不得不怀疑，这种模糊性在多大程度上渗透到了我们的潜意识中，不仅是孩子们的潜意识，甚至可能是我们自己的潜意识。你认为大多数虚拟助手被赋予女性名字和女性身份是个巧合吗？我认为这是市场研究以及人们压根没动脑子共同作用的结果。
I mean, I visited IBM Watson in Austin and there is a room that you can go into and you can talk to Watson and he has this deep, booming male voice and you can ask questions. And at the time I went there, there was a second AI in the room that turned on the lights and greeted the visitors and that one had a female voice. And I pointed that out and it seemed like they hadn't
我是说，我参观过奥斯汀的IBM Watson，有一个房间你可以进去和Watson对话，他有着低沉浑厚的男声，你可以向他提问。在我去的当时，房间里还有第二个AI，它可以开灯并迎接访客，而那个AI使用的是女声。我指出了这一点，但他们似乎并没有
really considered that. So it's a mixture of people thinking, oh, this is going to sell better, and people just not thinking at all, because the teams that are building this technology are predominantly young, white, and male, and they have these blind spots where they don't even consider what biases they might perpetuate through the design of these systems. So which brings us to the question of the sex robots. I'm curious what you make of this, and there are really complicated arguments
真正考虑过这个问题。所以这是人们认为“哦，这样会更好卖”，以及人们完全不过脑子的结合体，因为构建这项技术的团队主要由年轻、白人男性组成，他们存在盲区，甚至没有考虑通过这些系统的设计可能会延续什么样的偏见。这就把我们带到了性爱机器人的问题上。我很想知道你对这个问题的看法，关于这个问题的两方都有非常复杂的论证：
on both sides of this question. Should we use machines as sexual companions? Should we use them in ways that could potentially satisfy the needs of groups of people who in some ways we are troubled by? Yeah, so, you know, referring to pedophilia specifically, this is a very difficult area because we know almost nothing about pedophilia generally, and we have absolutely no idea what the effects of technologies like this could be
我们应该把机器当作性伴侣吗？我们应该以可能满足某些群体需求的方式使用它们吗？而这些群体的某些需求在某些方面让我们感到不安？是的，所以，提到恋童癖具体来说，这是一个非常困难的领域，因为我们对恋童癖整体几乎一无所知，而且我们完全不知道如果诸如此类的技术能够提供沉浸式的性体验，可能会产生什么影响
if they provide kind of an immersive sexual experience. I mean, it could be that this is a very useful outlet to use therapeutically, yeah, basically that ends up preventing real child abuse. And on the other hand, it could be that this is something that normalizes and perpetuates certain behaviors. And we literally have no idea what direction this goes in. And I think this is a question that we're going to be facing pretty soon.
。我的意思是，可能这是一种非常有用的治疗性宣泄渠道，是的，最终能防止真正的虐待儿童行为。另一方面，也可能这是一种使某些行为正常化并使其长期存在的东西。而我们对于它究竟会走向哪个方向可以说是毫无头绪。我认为这是我们很快就要面对的一个问题。
I mean, like you said, there are companies that make the dolls. There's legal cases already about this. And there's a lot of moral panic about sex technology. But also, I mean, in this case, very understandable emotional responses to regulation of child abuse. So, it's very difficult, and you can't research it in the US at least. So, you sometimes call a robot ethicist, and you've sometimes said, we might need to establish a limited legal status for robots. What do you mean by that? So yeah, it's a little bit of a provocation, but my sense is that if we have evidence
我是说，就像你说的，有一些公司在制造这种玩偶。已经有关于此的法律诉讼了。人们对性技术存在着巨大的道德恐慌。但同时，我的意思是，在这种情况下，人们对管制虐待儿童行为的情感反应是非常可以理解的。所以，这非常困难，至少在美国你无法对它进行研究。因此，你有时被称为机器人伦理学家，你有时说，我们可能需要为机器人建立有限的法律地位。你这是什么意思？所以，是的，这有点像一种挑衅，但我的感觉是，如果我们有证据
that behaving violently towards very life-like objects, not only tells us something about you as a person, but can also change people and desensitize them to that behavior in other contexts. So if you're used to kicking a robot dog, you know, are you more likely to kick a real dog? Then that might actually be an argument, if that's the case, to give robots certain legal protections the same way
表明对高度逼真的对象表现出暴力行为，不仅能反映出你个人的特质，而且还会在其他语境中改变人们并使他们对这种行为脱敏。如果你习惯于踢一个机器人狗，你知道，你踢一只真正的狗的可能性是不是会更大？那么，如果情况确实如此，这可能实际上构成了一个论据，即给予机器人某些法律保护，就像
that we give animals protections, but for a different reason. We like to tell ourselves that we give animals protection from abuse because they actually experience pain but for a different reason. We like to tell ourselves that we give animals protection from abuse because they actually experience pain and suffering. I actually don't think that's the only reason we do it, but for robots, the idea would be not that they experience anything, but rather that it's
我们给予动物保护一样，但原因不同。我们喜欢告诉自己，我们保护动物免受虐待是因为它们确实体验到痛苦和苦难，但原因不同。我其实并不认为那是我们这样做的唯一原因，但对于机器人来说，其出发点不会是它们体验到了什么，而是这会
desensitizing to us. And it has a negative effect on our behavior to be abusive towards the robots. So here's the thing that sort of it's worth pondering for a moment. If you hear, for example, that someone owns a bunch of chickens in their farm, right? So it's their farm, their chickens, they own the chickens. And they're really mistreating the chickens,
让我们变得麻木。对机器人实施虐待会对我们的行为产生负面影响。所以这里有一点是值得思考片刻的：如果你听说，例如，某人在他们的农场里养了一群鸡，对吧？所以这是他们的农场，他们的鸡，他们拥有这些鸡。而他们对这些鸡进行了极大的虐待、
torturing them, harming them. You could sort of make a property rights argument and say they can do whatever they want with that property. But I think many of us would say, even though the chicken belongs to you, there are certain things you can and cannot do with the chicken. And I'm not sure it's just about our concern that if you mistreat the chicken, that means you will turn into the kind of person who might mistreat other people. There is sort of a level, there is a certain moral level at which I think the idea of abusing
折磨、伤害。你可以提出一种财产权的论据，说他们对自己的财产想怎么处理就怎么处理。但我认为我们中的许多人会说，即使这只鸡属于你，有些事情你对这只鸡能做，有些事情你不能做。我不确定这是否仅仅源于我们的担忧：如果你虐待这只鸡，那就意味着你可能会变成那种虐待其他人的人。在某种层面上，我认为虐待
animals is offensive to us. And I'm wondering what the same thing is true with machines as well, which is it's not just the case that it might be that people who harm machines are also willing to harm humans, but just the act of harming things that look and feel and sound sentient is morally offensive in some way. Yeah, so I think that's absolutely how we've approached most animal protections, because it's very clear that we care more about certain animals than others
动物的想法在某种程度上是对我们道德的冒犯。我想知道这是否同样适用于机器，也就是说，不仅仅是伤害机器的人也可能愿意伤害人类，而是伤害那些看起来、感觉起来和听起来有感知能力的事物的行为本身就在某种程度上是对道德的冒犯。是的，所以我认为这绝对是我们处理大多数动物保护问题的方式，因为很明显，我们更在乎某些动物而不是其他动物，
and not based on any biological criteria. So I think that we just find it morally offensive, for example, to torture cats, or in the United States, we don't like the idea of eating horses, but in Europe, they're like, what's the difference between a horse and a cow? They're both delicious. So that's definitely how we tend to operate
这并不是基于任何生物学标准。所以我认为我们只是觉得在道德上被冒犯了，例如，折磨猫，或者在美国，我们不喜欢吃马肉的想法，但在欧洲，他们会说，马和牛有什么区别？它们都很美味。所以这绝对是我们倾向于运作的方式，
and how we tend to pass these laws. And I don't see why that couldn't also apply to machines once they get to a more advanced level where we really do perceive them as as lifelike and it is really offensive to us to see them be abused. The devil's advocate side of that argument of course is that would people then say pressing a switch and turning off a machine, that's unethical because you're essentially killing the robot.
也是我们倾向于通过这些法律的方式。我看不出为什么这不能同样适用于机器，一旦它们达到更高级的阶段，我们确实将它们视为生命体，而看到它们受到虐待让我们感到真正的道德冒犯。当然，这个论点的魔鬼代言人的一面是，人们会不会说，按下开关关掉一台机器是不道德的，因为你本质上是在杀死机器人。
But we don't protect animals from being killed. We just protect them from being treated unnecessarily cruelly. So I actually think animal abuse laws are a pretty good parallel here. You've argued that robots might one day expand the boundaries of how humans relate to one another. I want to play your short clip from the movie, Her, where a man falls in love with his operating system,
但是我们并不保护动物免于被杀害。我们只是保护它们免受不必要的残酷虐待。所以我实际上认为虐待动物法在这里是一个很好的类比。你曾辩称，机器人有一天可能会扩大人类相互交往的界限。我想播放你电影《她》中的一个小片段，里面一个男人爱上了他的操作系统，
but then discovers something about her. I'd love for anyone else. What makes you ask that? I don't know. Are you? I've been trying to figure out a talk to you about this. How many others? 600 free one.
但随后发现了关于她的一些事。我很想知道其他人会怎么想。你为什么这么问？我不知道。你是吗？我一直在想办法跟你谈谈这个。还有多少其他人？641人。
What? What are you talking about? That's insane. That's f***ing insane. So I'm wondering, is it possible that as we start to relate to machines, is it possible that they will change the range? Ways we relate to one another in other words, is it possible they'll expand how we think about relationships themselves? Maybe, but I think it's important to remember
什么？你在说什么？这太疯狂了。这他妈太疯狂了。所以我想知道，当我们开始与机器建立联系时，它们是否有可能改变人类相互交往的方式范围？换句话说，它们是否有可能扩展我们对关系本身的看法？也许吧，但我认为重要的是要记住
The thing that I couldn't get out of my mind when I was watching her specifically is that there is a company that makes this operating system and And if I were the company, I would program it to say, oh yes, I'm seeing 641 other people, but for $20,000, you can get exclusively me. Like, that's the direction it's going to go in, right? It's not that the machines are going to become conscious and develop their own forms of relationship. You mentioned Westworld some moments ago, and I want to play you a clip from Westworld
我在看《她》这部电影时挥之不去的一个想法是，有一家公司制造了这个操作系统，而如果我是这家公司，我会将其编程为：哦，是的，我正在和另外641个人交往，但只要花2万美元，你就可以独占我。这正是事情发展的方向，对吧？并不是说机器会变得有意识并发展出它们自己的交往形式。你刚才提到了《西部世界》，我想给你播放《西部世界》的一个片段
for those of you who haven't seen Westworld. Humans interact with robots in robots that are extremely lifelike, so lifelike that it's sometimes difficult to tell whether you're talking to a robot or you're talking to a human. In the scene that I'm about to play you, a man named William interacts with a woman who may or may not be a robot. You want to ask. So ask. Are you real?
对于那些没看过《西部世界》的人来说。人类与机器人互动，这些机器人极其逼真，逼真到有时很难分辨你是在和一个机器人说话还是在和一个真人说话。在我即将播放的场景中，一个叫威廉的男人和一个可能是也可能不是机器人的女人进行了互动。你想问就问吧。你是真人吗？
Well, if you can't tell, does it matter? So as I watched the scene and as I read your work, I actually had a thought and I wanted to sort of run the start experiment by you, which is that, you know, on one end of the spectrum we have these machines that are increasingly becoming lifelike, human like, you know, they respond in very intelligent ways, they seem as if they're alive. And on the other hand, we're learning all kinds of things about human beings that show us that even the most complex aspects of our minds
嗯，如果你分辨不出来，那重要吗？因此，当我观看这个场景并阅读你的作品时，我实际上产生了一个想法，并想向你做一个思想实验，那就是，你知道，在光谱的一端，我们有这些日益逼真、像人类一样的机器，你知道，它们以非常智能的方式做出反应，看起来就像它们是活的一样。而在另一端，我们正在了解关于人类的各种事情，这些事情向我们表明，即使是我们大脑中最复杂的方面
are governed by a set of rules and laws, and in some ways our minds function a little bit like machines. And I'm wondering, is there really a huge distinction? Is it possible? Is the real question not so much can machines become more human-like, but is it actually possible that humans are actually just highly evolved machines? I have no doubt that we are highly evolved machines. I don't think we understand how we work yet, and I don't think we're going to get to that understanding anytime soon, but yeah, I think I do think that we fall a set of rules and that we're essentially programmed. I don't distinguish between souls and other entities
受一套规则和法律的支配，在某种程度上，我们的大脑运作起来有点像机器。我在想，真的有那么大的区别吗？这可能吗？真正的问题与其说是机器能变得更像人类，不如说是人类其实有没有可能只是一台高度进化的机器？我毫不怀疑我们就是高度进化的机器。我不认为我们已经了解了我们的工作原理，我也不认为我们很快就能理解这一点，但是是的，我认为我们的确遵循一套规则，而且我们本质上是被编程的。我不区分灵魂和其他实体
without souls. And so it's much easier for me to say, yeah, it's probably all the same. But I can see that other people would find that distinction difficult. Do you ever talk about this? Do you ever run this by other people and sort of say, do you tell your husband, for example, I like you very much,
没有灵魂的实体。所以对我来说，说“是的，可能都一样”要容易得多。但我能理解其他人会觉得这种区别很难接受。你们讨论过这个吗？你有没有和别人探讨过这个，比如对你丈夫说，我非常喜欢你，
but I think you're a really intelligent machine that I love doing it. I haven't explicitly said that to him, but when you go home, from this trip. Yeah, we'll see how that goes. Kid Darling is a research specialist at the MIT Media Lab. Our conversation today was taped before a live audience at the Hotel Jerome in Aspen, Colorado
但我认为你只是一台我很喜欢的真正聪明的机器。我没有明确对他说过这个，但当你结束这次旅行回家后。是的，我们到时候看情况。凯特·达林是麻省理工学院媒体实验室的研究专家。我们今天的对话是在科罗拉多州阿斯彭的杰罗姆酒店在现场观众面前录制的
as part of the Aspen Ideas Festival. Kid, thank you for joining me to do a hidden break. Thank you so much. Thank you so much. Thank you. Hello. Thank you. Hello. This week's show was produced by Tara Boyle and Renee Thank you so much.
作为阿斯彭思想节的一部分。凯特，谢谢你加入我参与录制隐藏的大脑。非常感谢。非常感谢。谢谢。你好。谢谢。你好。本周的节目由塔拉·博伊尔和雷妮制作。非常感谢。
This week's show was produced by Tara Boyle and Renee Clar. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman, Raina Cohen and Barth Sha. Our unsung heroes this week are the staff of the Annabelle Inn in Aspen, Colorado. They kindly let us take over that conference center for several interviews with researchers who were in town for the Aspen Ideas Festival. They even turned off the fountains in their outdoor seating area so that we'd have studio quality sound while recording. Marie Kassenova, Doug Parks, Mike Clemens, thanks so much for your hospitality and your willingness to help us make a little bit of audio magic.
本周的节目由塔拉·博伊尔和雷妮·克拉尔制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼、雷娜·科恩和巴思·沙。我们本周的无名英雄是科罗拉多州阿斯彭安娜贝尔酒店的工作人员。他们友善地让我们接管了会议中心，以便与当时在城里参加阿斯彭思想节的研究人员进行多次采访。他们甚至关掉了户外休息区的喷泉，以便我们在录音时能有演播室级别的音质。玛丽·卡瑟诺娃、道格·帕克斯、迈克·克莱门斯，非常感谢你们的好客以及你们愿意帮助我们创造一点音频奇迹。
You can find photos and a video of Samantha, our Plio dinosaur, on our Instagram page. We're also on Facebook and Twitter and if you enjoyed this week's show, we'd love if you shared this episode with friends on social media. I'm Shankar Vita Anton and this is NPR. There we go. It just moved like a cow. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的Instagram页面上找到我们的普里奥恐龙萨曼莎的照片和视频。我们也在Facebook和Twitter上，如果您喜欢本周的节目，我们希望您能在社交媒体上与朋友分享这一集。我是香卡·维坦坦，这里是NPR。好了。它刚刚像牛一样动了一下。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。